we're joined Now by former BBC Royal
correspondent and historian Wesley Kerr
Wesley good morning to you you are the
perfect person to join us on this
particular day you know we all know that
the queen had been fragile for quite
some time yet Wesley when the news came
so many people were in shock so many
people were stunned by it why do you
think this queen was so beloved
well I think the suddenness of the event
was was astonishing that she should be
there
um welcoming her 15th Prime minutes so
just just two days before her death a
couple of weeks ago she hosted a dinner
party for 18 people apparently quite a
lively event so so the active to the end
and it's a rather upsetting I might
cried first thing this morning but to be
here where I've seen so many amazing
triumphant events seen her on the
balcony so many times her life actually
began only a mile away and Mayfair she
was born so it's very much a Londoner
and so special important to this place
but in terms of the the global impact I
might think that I mean I think it's the
most famous institution in the world who
could argue it's kind of up there with
with the papacy the British Monarchy and
immense the ancient institution our
ancestors have been ruling England for
1200 years I think she's this she was
the 61st Monarch and the 41st since
William the Conqueror but but the
longest serving of all of those and the
most famous of all of those and I think
the global impact I mean the
Commonwealth is is a is a third of the
population of the world a quarter of the
country is 45 countries which are now in
the United Nations became independent
during her Reign she she helped lead the
fight against apartheid she was
absolutely committed to the idea
um reading from the beginning of her
Reigns the old Empire was gone and it
was a partnership of equals and that
contributed to multiracial Multicultural
Britain
Wesley Wesley your knowledge is so vast
and I know that you you are your
encyclopedia when it comes to the queen
but I want to ask you this because you
say that it's significant when it that
she decided to spend her final days in
Scotland and passed away at Balmoral why
is that significant to you
well it was the routine one thing very
important to the queen was was the
routine so Balmoral was was one of her
very very happy places so many happy
summer holidays there with Philip and
with the children and that was just
where she would be in September but it's
incredibly important I think the United
Kingdom that she's um welcomed her new
prime minister in Scotland that she died
in Scotland people often say oh it's the
Queen of England it's the queen of the
United Kingdom a Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and I think actually
this moment where we're celebrating this
remarkable life is a moment of of
national unity and I think it's a
powerful moment internationally because
the the things that she stood for that
were good things she was a virtuous
monarchist a servant to her people into
the world
yes Wesley listen you covered her for
years you met her several times she
actually knew your name Wesley Kerr so
what does your password yes yes I know
she did what does her passing mean to
you personally
it's as though there was some great oak
tree that was outside
um on the horizon all your life and then
suddenly it's felled so I think she was
such a symbol of The Best of British and
such such a symbol of unity but just the
most wonderful warm human being and I
was privileged to meet her many times
over 30 years
um just that that's that sparkle the
smile the blue eyes
um she lit up a room whatever at any
Royal event was like as a marvelous
wedding or something
um she she she bought really love to
everybody
and Wesley she was working to The Bitter
End we thank you so much for your
knowledge I know we'll be in touch with
you for these next 10 days can't wait to
see you I love the oak tree so well
Leslie thank you we like that oak tree
analogy Wesley thank you so much